[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après leur épique match de rugby dans
l'album d'astérix chez les bretons les
irréductibles gaulois s'installe à
l'espace vers a de saint-germain-en-laye
au milieu de leurs confrères européens
j'ai appelé exposition bande dessinée
européenne spécialement passé dans le
cas du marché européen et vous verrez
qu'il ya des auteurs belges et des
français italien portugais espagnol
je crois qu'un suisse aussi un
yougoslave
en fait ils 21 français s'est ainsi bill
al dans nous avons une sérigraphie
[Musique]
entre son voyage sur la lune et sa
visite au temple du soleil
le célèbre journaliste d'hergé vous
observent et vient découvrir à vos côtés
les différentes étapes de création d'une
planche
vous voyez la liste de ses croquis il a
choisi d'ailleurs un pompier au canal
saint martin je soupçonne que ce soit le
pont ou dans un film d'époque
il y avait là l'actrice qui disait
atmosphère atmosphère
je suppose que c'est ce pont qui l'a
choisi et là vous voyez déjà le travail
d'encre de chine
la précision est pour arriver à la fin à
la plage aux couleurs plus de 75 pièces
sont exposées des planches originales
des ouvrages dédicacés et des sculptures
des maquettes classés par thématique
l'exposition débute avec un hommage à
didier savard dessinateur de la commune
décédé il ya trois ans j'ai contacté la
famille de didier savard qui a accepté
nous le prêter les planches originales
un collectionneur aussi privé de saint
germain nous a prêtés notamment ce livre
dédicacé par 10 des savoirs réalisé avec
l'aide de la librairie la marque jaune
et d'un collectionneur saint germanois
l'exposition la bande dessinée
européenne présente ses trésors jusqu'au
23 mai